yeah I went oops no and welcome to this
video play I am chess counter who is
that Zita the lobby Chandra ok so play
the good anti banco or whatever you may
call that obviously it's interesting
claim Oh what happens instead a real
sacrifice maybe it is or is it just a
blunder I still feel that I should be
quite ok here got quick development
going on we should be several no good
maybe hear hear something like stuff to
d6 I mean if he plays 19-6 now I will
just take it not so easy
we treat know about that Bishop age 49
f4 is very awkward but maybe I had to
discovery ideas anyway so goes back
there and yep what am i doing Knight b6
maybe try to do all that much well it is
a bit slow moving this again but it is a
concrete move I would like to take his
Bishop Ian for sure and where is he
going to ds3 there's c4 to be 334 and
Bishop a true I have Bishop a6
potentially
[Music]
just a concrete problem that he has now
letting me take it is also kind of cool
yeah maybe but yeah happy to take it and
now 96 let's take 95 94 comes into
consideration here I just wonder
directly or not i also have f 5 which is
interesting pretty much falling into
plain I 2d6 not quite sure this is
helpful
yeah maybe i'm not sure about this I can
prepare return you will play castles
probably anyway short casual or maybe
it's not no not no 96 okay now I
definitely play that c4 thing this was
why looks the aid pleased was a prep
move so that the rook the one that can
just take now yeah okay just just a
second this is six now there's no reason
to do that so yeah it's fairly now is
him how to do that maybe Queen g5 and
then g5 and you might take it might take
if I go jihad we should be five Queen d5
Queen g3 as possible
[Music]
25 he really just take that huh
ok
can just 26 and a bit download time
I'm not threatening inlaid with what
joke I was somewhat thinking I'm
threatening am a 22 oh my god that's
great I'm just like a million balls up
here and completely winning and then I
didn't wear your look that's not good my
god what the heck hahaha I was just
thinking I'm sure name it but it was
really great and destination Wow
everyone was completely busted I mean
completely busted okay I can of course
resign now so google+ no let me to
discuss it to resign yeah okay glad i
can what a fantastic hallucination yeah
the whole game was so completely
one-sided actually it's okay yeah this
is interesting thing I wasn't sure that
that that could be an interesting gambit
95 yeah it looks it looks interesting
ready the way it turned out I was just a
pawn up with at the beginning something
like this for Queen at three or so is
693 C 4 yeah it could be conversation I
mean let's click the song and something
like this is compensation also agreed on
by the engine yeah the way it was played
black which is completely winning like
here is more or less over this again
I just can play whatever just not London
the rook and summer I was thinking of
settling made at this really really
loose ination yeah the engine wants to
play king evade just cover this I mean
I'm two pawns up has the better
structure c2 is gone and so on which is
the one but ok so i can just cast me of
course I mean I'm not getting mated him
it was just a very really loosen ation
[Music]
huh very strange yeah well okay this is
not as good as king away that is still
basically it's basically still over
tanks and so on wow calm ya can only get
better next game okay thanks for
watching
[Music]